[Applause]
welcome thank you for wonderful
introduction my name is a Singh Hussein
you can find me on twitter as jaw ache
not Jewish a jaw ache and a blog about
angular and JavaScript and various other
things on my web site code Kraft TV and
what's called a cloud developer advocate
at Microsoft so we're a fairly new team
inside Microsoft we've only been around
for a year and that's our mascot bit so
we are the open source developer
advocate so my speciality is JavaScript
we've got people inside they're the team
they're specialized in all different
types of technologies if you go to the
link at the bottom there you can find
all of us there's about 60 of us right
now I'm also anybody here know udemy
anybody here my student on udemy yes
couple hands up fantastic so yes I'm
also an instructor on udemy and recently
they added in automatic subtitling for
all my texts and they and they correctly
replaced my name with with awesome so
hopefully this talk would be very
awesome but really over the past say
definitely the year or so things have
changed for me
so perhaps like this is my friend slide
so perhaps this is why we to describe
kind of what's happened to the other
last year I started web development and
I've gotten very much into machine
learning I he's been to machine learning
a long time ago he's a Python developer
back in a day so what me and Ellen are
who's the hair slide what mean eleda did
in London earlier on this year we both
very interested in machine learning
we're both very interested in JavaScript
we knew there were some very interesting
things happening inside this space so we
started a meetup group in London called
AI JavaScript which is actually being
growing very very fast really happy and
proud of it if you've got any good
questions they don't have stickers they
are jobs with stickers if anybody wants
any of them in exchange for a good
question so one of the things that
happened when we created this meetup in
in
London's a lot of people then send us
demos for interesting call AI power
JavaScript projects and we thought well
what we really want to do is create
website where we can just put all of
these demos so we can show people what
interesting stuffs happening inside this
space and that's exactly what we did we
launched it come on now a few months ago
it's called AI JavaScript Rox
a ijs rocks and if you go to the link
there what you'll find is a whole bunch
of AI powered
javascript demos each demo will have at
least a link so you can play around with
in the browser and get inspired or
what's possible and but then also should
have at least a link to the source code
so you can read and understand how they
built in hopefully we're doing some
interviews as well so hopefully you'll
find some videos and they're about with
the interviews with the author so they
can figure out how they built it it's a
resource to be inspired and then also to
learn and what I'm going to do today is
I'm going to go through about three
other demos that have been published on
the web stand and explain how it was
built and yeah I'm just gonna go through
it that way it's the first one the Mojo
fire okay it's not trademarked it's just
the mojo fire
so the mojo fire is going to change the
world
okay what it does takes an image any
guesses
[Music]
there's always somebody goes it modifies
it so congratulations you get sticker so
yes well it does it takes an image of a
face figures out the face in the image
the face in the image where it is okay
because that the emotion in the face
okay
take plates that matching emoji and puts
on the face okay that's the mode you
fire that's in a nutshell I'm Erin Lee I
originally released this as a Twitter
bot but before you get excited I don't
want to get too excited about this I
originally released it as a as a Twitter
bot so if you went onto Twitter and then
you saw any image and you replied with a
hashtag modify it would then emoji fine
don't get excited though I got what's
called shadow band on Twitter Sam you've
heard of the term shadow band before
it's the worst type of band you can ever
have on Twitter you get banned but
nobody tells you you're banned and you
can still tweet all that happens is that
nobody can see your tweets and know
everybody stops liking your tweets okay
it's a very bit of an issue for you if
you've got anxiety problems like I have
but it's very very hard to debug I tell
you that when I got shadow band so in
fact I've recently re-released this as a
slack bot so I'll give a link back to
that later on but there some interesting
things about this application right how
did you calculate emotion on a face how
did you actually do that yeah when I
tell you is actually really really
really easy okay really easy it's only
got two steps I knew two steps okay the
first step is you need to use some sort
of vision library to actually calculate
the different features of a face so
there's some very very important
standard features of a face the pupil
locations that forgot what this is
called there's different various
location that place there's a number of
different open computer vision libraries
that let you do that okay it's easy it's
easier to do it these days than it was
before and the second step really easy
is just to use an artificial neural
network okay yeah real good right
Jimmy to explain yeah okay fine I'll go
into it um so now switch on your network
is just this based upon its got asked a
basis in biology okay so this is a real
biological neuron you have dendrites
coming in a body and an axons going out
so if enough electricity flows in
through the dendrites the body goes okay
now enough electricity is flowing in I'm
gonna pass some electricity out again
okay and if you throw enough of these
things together you get a human brain
that's it
right yeah personally I believe there's
a little bit more to consciousness than
a bunch of neurons but everybody has
their own beliefs but um what you can do
is you can actually convert this into
something in code and if you think about
it it's quite standard it's not so hard
to understand how you might do this you
basically use just the graph so you have
these edges going into the graph a node
and edge going out okay you then might
pump some values in so for instance I
might pump some values in this may be
the number of mcdonnell's
in an area and the percentage house
price decrease in London is an actual
study than in London a while ago
inversely proportional house prices in
group umber see proportional to
McDonalds and proportional to coffee
shops and then what you do is you
basically the edges have weights but you
initially just randomized to some values
yes initially you randomized to some
values and then what you basically do is
you multiply all of these things out and
then they come back the end value sum it
up and you pass it through something
called an activation function and then
wherever that activation function passes
out you pass that out that's it just to
watch the screens go missing animation
now just explain a little bit more at
what's going on here
this is it okay it's just multiplication
all we're doing here is multiplicate
we take the input values we multiply
them by these weights we sum them
together we pass it through an
activation function and then whatever
that activation function pumps out that
is what gets passed on to another one on
to another one on to another one and
again these together get an artificial
neural network what's an activation
function there's loads of different
types of activation functions that you
use need to think about which ones you
you need for various use cases this is a
very simple one as very binary so if the
value is if the input value is below
zero its zero if it's above zero is one
okay it's not so great for some use
cases because small values result in big
output values so you might want to use
something like high points ham kind of
more grading or something like red to
vated linear unit but basically
whichever one you use you get or a bunch
of these perceptrons little neurons and
you connect them together into a neural
network that's it okay that's it you
initialize so this is a very very very
simple neural network has three inputs
one input layer one output layer two
hidden layers in between that's we call
hidden layer you initialize it
we initialize all of these edges with
random numbers I mean just cone reduce
initializing a bunch of random numbers
that's all you're doing and then you
pump some values in maybe these values
are the different positions all the
pupils of the mouth you can imagine if
you want to detect a smile you could
detect it this way you pump those values
in it just multiplies all those values
together gives you an output number this
is very very simple your network gives
you an output number maybe zero is
unhappy and ten is happy but we all know
that 3 is probably wrong for this
picture of me because I'm usually
looking very happy so we know the 3 is
wrong so we know this in your network is
giving us the wrong result right who's
probably I'm I know I'm probably an 8 so
I know it's off by 5 okay and this is
the kind of the the magic of a neural
network is how do you then if I know I'm
off by 5 how would you change those
little weights so the next time you pump
those values through it gives us an 8
and that's called back prop
that's called back propagation okay and
it's the process of then tweaking those
weights so that the next time you pass
those values through it will give us an
eight that's the training process that's
what you're doing when you train that's
the machine learning part of a neural
network and that's what you can do
there's actually a lot there's actually
data sets out there for with lots of
lots of different pictures that are
labeled already with people this is a
happy person this is a sad person you
actually lots and lots of different
examples custom for one person a picture
might look happy to another person might
look sad you need lots and lots of
different samples but he'd get them
enough you can train in your network
that can that can give you the answer
whether somebody's happy or sad okay you
can do that you can do that or you can
use an API this is what I use for mojo
fire user an API is the azure face API I
always find this a really unfortunate
picture that we have on our website I
don't even see it
she looks really confused I don't think
we should have a picture of somebody
looking confused but um this is all use
this is I use for the mojo fire and all
you have to do is post a path to an
image so you can post up the binary data
itself and I will turn you elect a bunch
of information is actually a subset of
the information so it gives you the
positions of the faces right which is
very important if you want to place an
emoji remember that's what we're doing
placing emojis you need to know the
positions of people spaces so you can
place an emoji but we also return an
object of emotions or anger contempt
disgust fear happiness happiness mutual
sadness and surprise little bit of a
fact here right now if you have a beard
you can never be a hundred percent happy
I've tried it's impossible so to
summarize neural networks are just
incredibly powerful in your network
sewing crap I'm gonna stay this this
as far as I'm gonna go stay here your
network so incredibly powerful okay
they've driven a large part of what's
been going on in the machine learning
space large part of the real
breakthroughs the past couple of years
right but the thing I want to get across
is that conceptually they're really easy
to understand okay I showed you the
basics of it in about five minutes
but they get much more complicated but
the basics of it you got in about five
minutes I hope you got in about five
minutes
okay next demo tensorflow mobile net and
I'm fine now this might need a little
bit of an explanation if you can read my
t-shirt right now so it's puppies Asia
and I'm flying so we did a Microsoft
conference earlier on this year where
our team specifically inside the middle
of this very normal conference we got
lots of puppies so as you're walking
around you could play with puppies
Stroke them is supposed to be for
therapy makes you much more relaxed and
we all got these little t-shirts puppies
Asha and I'm fine
and I gave her a workshop in London a
couple of months ago where I was wearing
one of these t-shirts that's teaching
people to use tensorflow
and so one of the attendees for the
workshop guy called Oliver actually went
away and then created a demo called
tensorflow
mobile net and I'm fine and that's the
next thing I'm going to talk about so
it's pretty simple it's just a code pin
right now you can all have a link to it
oops is a code pin I've got a video of
it working right now so what it does is
I don't if you can see yes so it's doing
a search on unsplash for an image and
it's an examining the image and then
telling you what it thinks is inside the
image okay so that's puppies has
returned uh this is uh what is that I'm
fine
a platypus that pull paddleboat okay
it's not great okay what would this one
fountain mmm not that good puppies okay
it's got Terrier okay it figured out
nine point four six percent it's a
terrier okay right so sometimes
an okay job and does a bad job but the
important thing I want to show you about
this demo okay is that the only API call
it's making us to unsplash to get the
image everything else is happening
inside the browser the detection of
what's in the image is happening inside
the browser all right
I miss using a technology was the hint
was entitled who isn't using a
technology called tensorflow
is any here use tensorflow I don't know
why I cannot see anybody in this
audience right now anybody using okay
cool
so what is tensorflow why is it so
called tensorflow is a technology the
open source by Google I think something
some years ago and it's for you could
different number of different things but
it's a tool that allows you to train but
one thing it's really good at to train
your networks it's a way of doing that
kind of training process that showed you
before it's a way of doing that
distributed across all the different
nodes in a GPU and across a bunch of
different nodes and a bunch of different
servers so it's really really powerful
putting a bunch of stuff like that but
recently I think five months ago five
months ago they released ok when I first
heard
about tensorflow das what I thought was
it was bindings for tensorflow the
installed application I thought you had
to install tensorflow on your computer
and once you'd install that you can then
interact with it with JavaScript that's
why I thought but it's not it's a
complete rewrite of tensorflow
in JavaScript completely right what does
that mean it means this it means in
order to use tensorflow in order to do
machine learning in the browser in
JavaScript all you need to do is well if
you're a proper developer you'd probably
use the top one
right if you like me you'll use the
bottom one okay
but this is it this is the all you need
to do is add one javascript library and
you can do machine learning in the
browser all right as a JavaScript
developer very exciting right there's a
bunch of different things you can do
with it you can train models so you can
do the thing I showed you before with
the neural network and you can
initialize values and back propagate and
train them and tweak the wage you can do
that with it but another thing you can
do with it is load a pre trained model
okay there's lots of different machine
learning models out there you can
download them you can there's they've
got converter packages we convert them
into Jason and you can load them up in
tensorflow J so you can I have something
has just been trained using Python then
loaded up using javascript and what
Oliver had done is he basically used one
of those packages called mobile met him
mobile net is it's been trained up to
recognize about thousand different
images it's small enough so it can be
loaded up in the browser and that's what
he used so you can see it's actually
going to go up and got a few a few lines
this is this is it this is its you load
up mobile in there you get an image tag
you load the model the model is quite
large and then you pass it to classify
and it gives you those percentages of
what it thinks inside the model it's not
very good okay but it's fine it's this
you actually use things like this for
something
called transfer learning which is more
useful but weed out time to go into that
today you could do that you could do
that way or you can use an API so
they're shoes again I need to speak to
mine and Microsoft people you guys need
to change here we have something called
the computer vision library which kind
does similar things because the mobile
net to be small enough to be loaded up
in the browser you can't we do can't
really detect a lot of things if you
want to detect a larger range of things
you need to use a much much larger model
which isn't really feasible to be loaded
up inside the browser so you want to put
it on a server somewhere and wrap it in
an API lots of different cloud powered
people companies out there have API is
that let you do this we've got one
called computer vision my colleague
Sarah Dresner created a cool little demo
again this is on AI J ROCs as well but
she create a cool little demo which is
for accessibility okay so in a website
you could take it can examine an image
and create an alt text to put in for
screen readers okay this is her demo and
it's kind of a bit crazy this if you
actually passed this image to the azure
computer vision API it returns that
caption at the top a black and white
photo of Thomas Edison the text says hey
girl did we just share electrons because
I'm feeling a covalent bond between us I
don't understand magic I'm sorry but the
important thing I want to show you about
this is that it didn't just say a black
and white photo of a guy I knew was
Thomas Edison and extracted the text
from the image as well so it does a
whole load of other things but it
doesn't always get it right okay as with
everything nothing's perfect this is a
couple of other people once you released
it post it on Twitter other other
answers it was giving so this is a
star-filled sky the text says I think
that's asian for something the next one
I'm not too sure I think the next one
could actually be correct
of stuffed animals on a because they
could be stuffed you don't know maybe
they are the next one I really like
because I think we were half right they
were half right with the next one half
right okay so pretty good just to
summarize okay so the thing that if
you're gonna take one thing away from
this talk if you only take one thing
away from this talk just take this
tensorflow jeaious doesn't have any
dependencies okay you could just drop it
in to an application start doing machine
learning in Java that's it okay
mobile that is a really simple way to
you can use to analyze images use it for
other things but the easy way to get
started and if you really want to do
something more important more
significant you need to use an API right
now so as your computer vision is a good
API that you can use for that okay I'm
running out of time I wanna get to the
next one because x1 is my favorite right
image to image don't play video
[Music]
okay so image to image is a really good
demo really fun what does it do it
basically if you draw the outline of a
cat it will fill in the rest of the cat
okay it's a really good that most by a
guy called
Ziad who I interviewed his into he's
gonna go on air Jess rocks shortly it's
still a student I was not doing stuff
like this when I was a student be a
really interesting stuff but I want to
talk about how he made he made it using
an algorithm called pics to pics I'm a
system called generative adversarial
neural networks
okay the really interesting space and
I'm hopefully I'm gonna have time to
take you through it all so a generative
adversarial neural network is actually
two neural networks competing with each
other competing with each other right so
you've got one which is the generator
and the other one which is the
discriminator to the generator
the generators job is to create images
of cats the discriminators job is to
detect if the image is a generated image
or a real image of a cat okay but gain
these are just neural networks so they
initialize with a bunch of random values
what you pass in the generator is a
sketch of a cat just the sketch you pass
it in you pass it in and remember the
weights all randomized initially they'll
randomized it's not we going to create a
good image of a cat it's probably just
going to create static okay so for all
the sketches it generates a bunch of
static images and then it passes up - it
passes all those images to the
discriminator I'm just going to give up
on that so the discriminator and then
the discriminator gets all of the static
images and all the real images of cats
and then has to go and figure out if
it's a real image or a fake image okay
again the discriminate is randomized at
the start it's not really going to do a
great job to begin with a discriminating
right so for instance it might say the
cat is the fake image and the static is
the real image it might say that
begin with and then it would be wrong
and once it's wrong what you do you want
to retrain those weights and next time
it does it better so if it's wrong it
would then retrain the weights and the
discriminator so next time it it gets
asked it does a better job but they
figure out the other way around then the
descript then the generator knows it's
wrong so the generator then gets
retrained and the generator gets better
it generates images until eventually
what happens is the generator gets
really really good at crank at images so
good that the discriminator can't really
tell the difference can't we tell the
difference okay
and so they want to then it's done it's
done is created okay and then then we
take you to take that generator model
what see I did is he he exported that
into format that can be used in
tensorflow das and put that in the
website okay and so then what will you
have to do is import your own sketch of
a cat and it's going to try and create a
sketch of a cat country
picture of X of a cat right why is this
important like joking around with cats
right why is this important what's the
significance of this I think this is one
of the most important parts of machine
learning has been coming on along
recently especially to all of you here
who are web developers because you can
do a bunch of different things with it
so this the stuff might want to show you
now is does not work in the browser yet
okay but then this is another similar
algorithm called vid to vid okay so the
images on the right are generated from
the images from the sketches on the Left
they're generated right okay
gets a bit more interesting you can
create different people how about this
[Music]
she's not dancing this is a segmented
image of somebody else dancing a segment
the image and it's been laid and kind of
like it's generating her image dancing
that makes sense okay there's this one
this is another interesting one it's
just a segmented image so the top left
is the input image there's different
algorithms playing along here that the
top right is a picks to pick the same
literally the same algorithms used to
generate the cats but it's for picture
by picture for frame by frame it's not
so good vid by vid to vid is the bottom
right it's pretty good it's generated if
you look very very closely it's got some
issues there's a it's kind of a blob
walking out of a car with on your legs
things like that right and it gets even
more interesting hopefully I'm going to
be able to do here so something we
created inside Microsoft is we can't
recreate images of birds so then we want
to describe to me an image of a bird a
what color bird red a red bird with what
color beak blue anything else about the
bird small pointy feathers yeah two
heads let's try it okay well last thing
that's enough for now
okay it's created it okay pretty well we
said red with with with with uh why
don't we see I can't remember anyway so
this is generated okay this is generated
by the by various algorithms and creates
in the browser and it's a game is
generated using a generative adversary
on your network all right
pretty scary right yeah how far away do
you think we are how far away do you
think we are from creating something
where you can type in make me a website
with a header a contact button etc how
far away do you think we are yeah I
created something it's call form gun it
generates a form for you yeah then we
want to give me give me a form so if a
form with three input fields the first
is a text area all right well next the
next is a file picker
I can't picker and the third is a passer
field yeah you ready
I did
so it doesn't exist I was joking
I asked Ola for a song he said this is
his favorite song and he said all the
Ukrainians would love this song so true
so um it doesn't exist right but we're
not far off I showed you something that
made birds right that people are really
are working in this space and there are
things happening here
okay so scary or maybe not so um so just
to summarize so Gans
they learn to generate new images okay
they actually take a lot of compute to
train a lot of computer train more than
a normal neural network okay so the but
the generated models are they create can
be run of the browser so take a little
computer train but you can actually
optimize it enough to download it and
converting habits to be used the browser
intensified jes a few other things want
to just leave you with if you want to
find out more and from if you know learn
how to build something like the moji
fire I've got a link here you can go to
you can take a picture you take a
picture and that that link will take you
to something to show you how to create
the moji fire I also want to say I'd
recommend if you are interested in to
learn a little bit more about tensorflow
Jas taro is gonna be speaking next about
music and AI and the browser tensorflow
and magenta Jas so he's gonna be talking
about how to use tensorflow Jas to do to
make music in the browser so stay here
if you want to go for that final
thoughts just a few final thoughts I
totally want to I know I scared
everybody here in the audience hopefully
with this talk today but I just really
wanted to tell you it's the question I
have been asking myself at least the
last year okay so where where do we fit
in as web jobs with developers where do
we fit in into the a I'm a ceiling
revolution is happening throughout the
world right
okay and I'd say that kind of twenty
years ago we were just web developers I
saw with where we web developers and now
we've got all these different roles
front-end back-end UX product DevOps as
a field grow the specializations up here
okay so I see a future where there's a
specialization for a JavaScript
developer in the machine learning space
machine learning JavaScript engineer for
our meetup in London the a our jobs can
meet up when we created it we expect to
the only people to turn up to be
JavaScript people wanting to learn
machine learning but actually half the
people turn to a meet-up our data
scientists machine learning engineers
who want to learn JavaScript because
it's a great way of taking this amazing
work that they've done and production
izing it I'm making something actual
tangible on the web with it okay so
that's what I'm gonna say is I think
there's a future where there's got me a
machine learning JavaScript engineer and
you don't need to know if you don't need
to sit down read PhD papers all day you
just need to know the basics okay so
that's it thank you very much your time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]